My husband called me from the office craving a pumpkin pie,
so I got to work that afternoon.
We're starting with a homemade crust,
of course, using glyphosate free flour and pasteurized butter.
After trimming the excess,
I crimp the edges for a decorative look using my thumb.
I throw this in the freezer
and then get to making some homemade pumpkin puree
by baking sugar pie pumpkins for 40 minutes until soft.
I then puree the flash until it's soft,
smooth and creamy. Then
I pop the frozen crust into the oven for a 15 minute pre bake
at 425 degrees every night.
Filling comes together in no time in one medium sized bowl in pie
spice, salt,
coconut sugar, pumpkin puree,
rock cream, pasture raised eggs and vanilla
and stirred the filling
and then we poured it into the pre baked pie shell.
This baked for 35 minutes until set but still slightly jiggly
and cooled overnight. We cut into it one evening later.
It was perfectly pumpkin scrumptious with healthy ingredients.